[Music]
have any of you guys ever been an extra
on set i have you have for one for a
commercial what'd you have to do only
leading role you know what's funny it
was my buddy was directing um
you guys ever heard of round one oh yeah
you've heard of round table pizza it's
like a japanese made like dave and
buster's awesome and um it was the
weirdest commercial ever but like i had
to be in the back pretending like i was
drinking a beer playing pool like whoa
we're having fun like you were in a
round one commercial was it a beer or
was it like some [ __ ] tea or some
[ __ ] it was yerba mate tea
how long were you there i was there for
all day yeah just for that one scene yes
sir i was i wasn't is it yerba mate i
have no idea i've always just said yerba
mate i've said that too yeah i've been
cussed out for saying it wrong okay so
it's yerba you better watch it also
can we
[Music]
sponsored by
i was an extra for comics unleashed with
byron no [ __ ] way you're [ __ ]
serious the show we've been making fun
of this whole time you never brought
that up i didn't bring it up no i
thought i did no you didn't dude what
did you do you talked about it why oh
dude i was just in the [ __ ] audience
we're all over there
we're trying to be we have we had to be
seals did you ever have any real
laughter no bro honestly it was a really
brutal day really brutal dark day
dark day for comedy all around how much
you get paid for that dude we got like
50 bucks and we spent like 30 of it at
taco bell after it was a really dumb day
really dumb day that's a lot of food i
talk about that's hella dude that's like
a week's worth video for me and my buddy
too and i was like god damn this is
probably like 20 [ __ ] eight dollars
somebody sucks
it's half our money
there's a lot of fake popping for money
have you guys ever been on or anthony
you've probably been on set and so all
of you guys have probably been upset you
ever hang out with the extras tent like
like once you were done being an expert
yeah it gets weird it gets weird in
there oh bro extras are like a whole
nother level said the extra
well well then i was in i was in a film
um uh god called the wedding ringer with
kevin hart right an old cat with my butt
right okay yeah
and i was in there but i was a featured
i was featured
so that featured extra features
so so that's the thing right that's the
best part is that like you know i
basically got this role because of my
youtube channel and they're like we want
you to [ __ ] promote the movie with
through your youtube [ __ ] so i was like
whatever sure cool um they didn't really
say that but that was kind of the
understanding and then so i show up and
like i'm supposed to be like a groom or
some [ __ ] and we i'm in the movie a
little bit
and then afterwards the the extras like
come up to me like in the parking lot
and like you get a bump did you get a
bump and i'm like the [ __ ] you're
talking about drugs
this is where it gets weird like you
were you're definitely on camera day
you're you're definitely getting a bump
you better tell them that you better
tell them that and then
yeah and they're like you get to eat the
hot food too they can't even they can't
shoot you away with the broom they got
they have to feed you the hot food dude
you were their like hero because they
thought you were originally out of them
who graduated oh my god yeah and they're
like how was the hot food is it good
how was the pump tell me about the bob
what do you like oh i tried to go over
there and they're like
out of here
they separated the featured and the
regular they drew
when i was my first thing i ever did
that was professional was i was an extra
in a papa roach music video for scars no
way
i just remembered that at one point
uh and i feel like this was nefariously
done we were on set and then uh they
were like yo
uh is any two girls here want to make
out for the for the video ryan and then
immediately ryan and eric i just
remember thinking like damn that's
that's pretty [ __ ] cool they're
definitely gonna be in the video and
then these two girls they made them like
make out so many times they filmed it
and all [ __ ] are they featured like can
you guys take off your shirts now they
weren't even in the video at all
get the [ __ ] out of here i really think
they were just [ __ ] around yeah
because like they didn't they're not
even in the video as extras at all did
they even record them they were just
like i don't know i thought they were
because they they weren't even
irish okay
just put your name on this list
i was in a music video we were filming
it like so [ __ ] late at night it was
so hot in la it was like [ __ ] 104
degrees at night even and i was there
with you guys remember glozell yeah
she's a sweetie i love glozell so it was
me and her the whole time we're like
dancing for this [ __ ] music video
against like whatever the hell you're
such a dancer i don't even dude the best
style dude my style was [ __ ] killing
it
i was bringing the [ __ ] heat right
yeah bringing the funk jujitsu dance and
the best thing is like me and godzilla
like i probably looked like i just
walked out of a pool as i left there i
was so sweaty and [ __ ] and then i
finally see the music video and i'm not
in it one time not even one frame not
even the back of my [ __ ] head
glozell is all over the [ __ ]
thing i don't even know how they cut me
out of it
movie magic bro movie magic they've
probably
brought in industrial light and magic to
[ __ ] edit you out pay george lucas's
company to [ __ ] get me out of there
so i thought it'd be funny we're gonna
look at some times when in really
popular movies where an extra ruin the
scene oh
nice
starting with all the reasons why i
watched starting with alpha alfred
hitchcock this is a 1959 movie called
north by northwest there's a scene that
they were running over and over where a
gunshot happens a [ __ ] kid knows it's
coming and it goes like this right
before
continuity
wow
watch him in the back he's like sitting
at the table
he's right here
she shot carrie grant is that him and
there's mount rushmore right in the back
man who the [ __ ] in mount rushmore you
can't see it what the hell that's not
the let me see that [ __ ] here's mount
rushmore
if that's real then that's like the like
that that's really there's a place
there's mile rushmore right there that's
that's the scene that's the privilege
for only like wait mount rushmore is
white colored that's mount rushmo oh wow
what did you think it was black people
yeah i thought it was the king i thought
it was a kings of comedy but he told me
that you can't even see mount rushmore
dude it's so hard to see can we can we
do that again but i can i have that line
yeah yeah yeah steve one second i want
that line just try it all right go ahead
and take it from the top i'll go like
this before all right
here's another scene in teen wolf where
an extra stands up you know like when
you're an extra and you're well i guess
you don't have to be an extra for this
but you know when you sit down and you
got a little fupa going so you unbutton
your pants so it's a little bit easier
yeah long days you're gonna do that this
person did that forgot that it was
unbuttoned stood up and then uh yeah you
see the rest
right there
[Laughter]
that's that's real life though that's
real life that's real life that's real
life that's a real person that's okay i
like the fumble yeah as a director is
that ground shirt reshoot or just go
[ __ ] oh absolutely not zoom in
as an editor i would zoom in as a as a
director like what's his name that guy's
a star you give me his name it's been
discovered dude or it's just like hey
who are the guys that got steve green
out of that other video we need their
help yeah and they're like they're like
man that's gonna [ __ ] work but
i love the ad-libs this one i don't know
if this is like a joke but it's from the
will ferrell movie everything must go
maybe you would know if it was like a
gag but there's a scene where these kids
are just kicking it right here
while they're having a conversation
and then when it cuts back later on the
kids are like dead frozen
look you'll see them in the back
oh my god
what
that's weird that i mean with will
ferrell you just never know though
wait what that was so awkward i think
they would just pan over to the kids be
like
they're just like
there's this [ __ ] there's this
[ __ ] clint eastwood movie this old
clint eastwood movie what the [ __ ] up
i don't let him talk
so just before he's gonna kiss this
little girl there's a guy in the
background that's like
stupid
have you seen that before you know the
clip very fast
you should watch the movie it's really
good you heard it old enough for kisses
am i old enough for kisses is this what
you said am i old enough
there was a there was a very disturbing
clint eastwood movie that we referenced
that has probably one of the and at the
end we'll just show it to you and get a
reaction because there's anyone that's
new here we got to get their lives okay
yeah but for now we're going to go and
check out mr nanny mr nadine a classic
do you know about the little easter egg
in this oh so this one's not really an
extra it might actually be a real
[ __ ] dude throwing a montage sorry so
in this montage when he's on a bike
going by
in the background a dude's just tossing
his dog into the water oh my god oh i've
heard about that
well it's a little eerie
[ __ ] though
you remember this right this is the
whole pokemon right yep
so look at the background
why
oh my god they kept that in there
because it's very like apparent
like they couldn't put that threw that
dog in there because they needed to get
this shot of hulk hogan doing this
you're going to learn how to swim
that was the expense like that we've got
to have this you got to know he wipes
his nose no one will believe he's really
there unless you see this what the [ __ ]
it's really [ __ ] weird the editor
probably did that as a joke because he
it was probably like real and he's like
we're gonna we gotta leave that [ __ ]
in there you do editing jokes when you
edit stuff i wish
that happened
i mean they're their times but
she's not as apparent as that all right
this next one brings us to quantum of
solace
there's a guy sweeping in the background
and his room's not even touching the
ground
[Music]
[Laughter]
why why why
it's harder to not sweep
isn't it why
this might be a hot take but that guy he
should die dude no it's the same thing
like directors tell all the extras to
just walk normally and they're like yeah
same arm same way
you're like is that you do you think
that could be a thing where like they
don't want to make noise i was thinking
that too like sound
like can you pretend because the sound
is messing but the thing is
does that depending on the budget they
have props that won't matter right
right like paper bags that are totally
silent right right oh wow he can't just
be walking in the background or maybe he
did it like the first time and then a
bunch of dust came up and stuff like
that and like ruined areas of the shots
just like he's doing it too hard
we just need all these extras to explain
themselves pretty much yeah it's so
difficult to not let it touch the floor
yeah it's impossible it's a lot of work
yeah you gotta hover it this one this is
from dark knight rises oh yeah this is
there's a stunt guy right here you seen
this one yeah you know about this yeah
so in the stunt world this is like a
known one yeah this is like very okay
because we all saw it in [ __ ] imax
tell us more about this
after you watch when it comes to this
guy doesn't get hit by anything he
[ __ ] gets knocked out look
i mean it's so dark it happens a few
times
oh it does
what was the reason
are these are these actual stud guys or
is that just an extra that was asked to
be another dude you know
funny you say that that does happen a
lot sometimes um really they're just
sometimes yeah sometimes and that's more
prevalent
yeah that's never the only one and then
what are they doing they're just
standing there and then they're like
there's no bad guys so they're just like
oh
or the choreography was done differently
and just the continuity and then he's
just like well i'm just doing muscle
memory at this point like i don't know i
mean there were so many things that were
just
that you said that's never an option you
mean like it's it's always a bad idea to
ask a non-stunt guy to just do a style
and the people who are the actual stunt
men or women on set they're like
it's like telling somebody to like jump
in choreography for a day
that you've been rehearsing for the past
few weeks let's just have this person
who has no idea what they're doing what
do you think happened in that movie
because i agree with you like the third
act that whole huge extra fight scene is
like wow the stunts and the fight scenes
were just uh
terrible it didn't even look like they
were actually fighting each other in the
entire third act yeah really bad was
that what with the cops and the cops
from the bane and all that jail prison
guys yeah yeah i think there's one
training sequence in tenet also that is
hilarious when you look at the
choreography it's like
and you know choreography
you're a bad boy choreo all right this
one's uh these are the last ones we're
gonna do uh this is from i think what
does this you only live twice
classic uh there's an explosion that
happens the bad guy holds a cat for most
of that movie the explosion freaks the
cat out you can see the cat visibly just
like going through it
look at this cat he's holding it
[Laughter]
look at the look at the vice grip he's
going off dr evil look at the whole
movie it's usually just like a docile
like you know it's part of his like
costume the cat's like get me out of
this [ __ ]
he's not slowing onto it like for dear
life trying to finish poor cat bro poor
cat i know so we're gonna we're gonna
end this by showing her the mcb clip i'm
just going to see what you think so we
want to see your your thoughts as a
director and like what kind of choices
would you do
would you change any of this or yeah and
maybe the coloration something yeah
color grading all right this is purely
for colleen ready
wait hold on i can't with this and
what's the character's motivation this
instantly
oh thank you
wait where's the little x we can wait
just install it
there you go there you go now we're
gonna install it
live on camera and update it leave it in
leave it in
leave it in
everybody
but everybody calls me
so like what would you do like how would
you how do you film that like is it the
color range i thought it was too dark
like it's it they needed to light it up
more it was not it was it wasn't that
good i agree i think they needed like a
bounce board or something i mean i'm no
expert you're really good to him like
growing up or something yeah
do you think do you think people really
call him mcbee
i think she does that
do you think your birthday's really in
september
i don't think so i think she was lying
do you think they're real actors
i think they used
a kid double
yeah they brought in a 12 year old boy
right after his stunt double for the
kids so anytime you say old enough for
kisses that's what we're talking about
okay
um final thoughts
after seeing a bunch of extras [ __ ]
up scenes yeah and then this is the
first time we got to show a girl this
this clip so yeah we're all pretty
excited right
pretty excited really stoked about
getting people
[Applause]
what do you think about our show
i have more questions
than
comments
i have more questions he's the guy with
the answers you have the answers i have
a couple okay uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you